he's BK BMG same on Instagram as well
for Brooklyn boy makes good loved his
work in the wire as well as Boardwalk
Empire and now in the public which
premieres in theaters today April 5th
good to see you Michael KQ ace man thank
you so you are from Flatbush right from
the Bradys Flatbush memory and you're on
your your clothing line Kings County New
York right no right can you imagine like
this was this is open right I took it
right it's it's it's it's pretty cool to
see as you said a Brooklyn boy making
good are you are you a fan of any
specific at all New York team is there
one that you you want to see win more
than any other I mean you know of course
you know at first my first love is the
Knicks okay be good to see them to have
a shot at the brass ring hmm
one more time one more time Oh more
again as we say right exactly I mean so
who's back in the day when you were
first fall in love with him who at which
is your who's your guy man you know I'm
blanking on names right now of course a
clod would that be Clyde would be number
one was on what's my brother's name real
tall brother okay well there's many of
them there's Willis Reed from back in
the day nah man thank you about yeah
doing Patrick Ewing
Patrick Ewing man I remember going to
the games and seeing him you know with
the UM with the UH with his you know
with his his ice pack song man and it's
you know he put the towels over him oh
yeah he really um he gave her some time
he gave us he gave his all to the to the
spirit of the game and I you know just I
remember the spirit of the team is
exciting my guy was Bernard King when I
was growing up here in New York City
I just loved him and loved the Knicks
love going to Madison Square Garden you
know now there's a team in Brooklyn
I know Lynette so I had the Brooklyn
Nets right over there right just and
part of the whole revitalization of
certain parts of the borough it did
pretty good decision they did they're in
they're in a playoff position right here
right yeah don't really said you yeah
you know and it's funny that you are is
New York through and through as you
possibly can be and yet so many people
obviously equate you at the city of
Baltimore because if your role in the
wired you find that really weird anyway
so you know not
really um when I went into the character
I I purposely I purposely did not want
him to sound like a dude from Brooklyn
you know he was Omar was born and bred
in Baltimore and so he should walk and
talk and sound like a dude from
Baltimore so I immediately I soaked up
the culture the dialect nor that stuff
and and then I fell in love with the
city you know so um it's Baltimore sadly
my second home is that right oh yeah you
know you got any given day you could
find me at the bar at Jimmy's seafood
restaurant right there you know I still
have friends on the west side of
Baltimore shout out to uh my friend and
mentor farmer Nell you know I'm so I
have a lot of roots a lot of a lot of
ties and roots in Baltimore that that
was that were born from the why so how
do you cuz I can hear the a yet the New
York accent in you right now I'm here
and it with me you know if you cut me
off in traffic it will cut off the road
rage
Michael is where it will really come out
I've calmed down in my ears okay but so
what did you do to get the Baltimore I
guess the accent that you would think it
would be picked up what you do I mean I
I just absorbed it that I went into the
streets I went to the streets I've met
people you know I would I would sit for
hours and frail ease of the in the back
of the legends in a market and I would
just listen to random conversations of
people coming and going and it was just
were so vibrant but when I started
really making friends and um having
relationships with the community again
farm Annelle or out of the friend of
mine Darrell Wilson I mean a lot of
athletes you know are free Antonio
Freeman Sam Cassell these are these are
men that that took me into their into
their families to their communities and
you hang around them long enough you
gonna pick that dial echo Sam Cassell
huh yeah man god bless the dead um my
brother um he was he played for the
Falcons I'm blanking on his name right
now he just recently passed um chipped
falling with his song playing with his
son he fell he's also football team
played on the Falcons I'll key on
carpenter you know um he's a lot of good
you know there I saved Carmelo Anthony I
know back in days when he was a baby
running around the streets of Baltimore
so I had a lot of
good friends to UM to help me get in
character said last night so let me let
me stop it stop you at Carmelo Anthony
what what how did you come across him
meet him Michael
again Oh carmella was a he was a he was
a prince of the city very early on like
you know um I remember once I started
hanging around the elite athletes of the
city like of the midnight Thames I just
called you know what it was on it wasn't
before long that I was I got to meet
Carmelo and go to his you know back when
his mom was living in Baltimore got to
me to spam this is before this is just
he was just about to go I mean Pro you
know I mean but he was about to probably
head off to Syracuse exactly the same
thing for lunch well which is like no
French maybe that is kind of like going
pro maybe we need it
wow I'm sorry Wow he's a Syracuse but no
that's when he was getting off to go to
the big time yeah yeah for sure
and that's when you were just beginning
to work on the wire and this was exactly
and it's amazing how Jesus OCS fall
timorous OC ated from New York from
Brooklyn I know it's incredible how
these things happen in your Brooklyn is
associated with Baltimore in that regard
Michael Kay Williams here on the Rich
Eisen show let's talk about the public
it's in theaters today you are part of
now this is this a fascinating movie how
did you get hooked up with with Emilio
Estevez for this film Michael you know
Emilio Jesse no he calls you and when
Emilio calls you you take the call right
and um it was plain and simple you know
I got a phone call that he was on he was
interested in me for the role of Jackson
and I was such a huge fan of his I mean
from the work he did just in front of
the camera then would be Bobby things he
didn't behind I delivered the
opportunity just to have a conversation
with him and then once I read the script
it was a wrap it was a wrap I I knew I
had to be a part of yeah it's about a a
library that's taken over by a homeless
and Cincinnati agents Ryan get out of
the cold and seek shelter and you're
part of the crew of home
folks that uh that take over the the
shelter did you learn anything I learned
a lot rich you know um I learned a lot
of things that I forgot actually um the
first thing I remembered that I've I
remember it was on how important the
library was to the community how much of
a vital staple it is especially to a
working-class community that look what I
came from I had I realized how far away
I had gotten from that reality you know
um
now that I have I could afford to buy a
laptop you know I guess I thought I
didn't need the library you know um and
I forgotten how valuable it is of an
institution to the community still to
this day you know everyone can afford
laptops or computers everyone doesn't
have good um or can afford any internet
to send off resumes to talk to family
members that may be out in the country
the library still are still important
for a lot of people who who find needs
to do things like that and can't do it
it from from from their home right yeah
they can't go online there's no
smartphone no it's actually an actual
book any place where you can go get them
and it's free its to the poet's to the
public and it's one of the last places
in our country that you can go to with
dignity and don't have to let that not
be made to spend any money and you can
get things done and it's in a clean safe
environment you know but um you know due
to our homes our our people who don't
have the situation with people who don't
live on or in homes I'm trying to get
away from the word homeless I know
there's because it's it detaches me from
the fact that they're part of my
community so you know when we have
situation where people or not are
falling through the cracks and they last
their last place of dignity is to go to
the public library that's it's just a
song it's such a cry for help but at the
same token thank God that it's there and
in this film it's also a refuge from
from the cold hell of a cash man that
you are with right yeah there's some
pretty good company I know you rich some
really good company and you got
alec baldwin taylor schilling hugh
jeffrey wright is we had him on the show
he's a die-hard Washington Redskins
family he's okay yeah yeah he's he's uh
he's got some he's got some thoughts on
the world as well
I love Jeffery right I follow him on
Twitter and it's uh it's eventful yeah
it is eventful I mean David Simon
they're out there oh my god David Simon
it was the creator of The Wire he's an
interesting follow I I can't really say
what he says on his account yeah because
it's not safe for work
ya know it's quite a bit yes what was it
like having words of his that he wrote
come out of your mouth you know I just
recently found out that David was
messing with me man they they started
giving me all this mythology mythology
mythology and Greek esque type little
dialog to mess with me it got to the
point where they was like well I guess
well he nailed that okay well he nailed
that if he could see so good let's if
you get this just right okay throw me
like all that you know the Luke this you
know I heard this in a random interview
but it would just you know I was like
you know okay yeah so well so that's
what it was like to work with David make
things more and more difficult for you
because you you were well enough with
these what a compliment right I mean to
have someone like David Simon um give me
a extra credit homework because he felt
he felt that I could home he want to see
if he want to challenge me to see if I
had it right to even get to that level
with someone that writes on his level
Islam it's a compliment I would take
that as a comment you should you should
cuz you're awesome at what you do have
I've got new you bet I've got a couple
of facts that we noticed about you in
articles that were written about you in
other interviews that you had and can we
play celebrity true or false with
Michael K Williams all right it's all
true but I mean I thought counseling you
know you haven't heard the question okay
okay we can we
true even it real first film role was a
result of Tupac picking your picture off
a wall and declaring that you looked
like you could play his little brother
in the film bullet is that true that is
true what was that about I mean you said
it more accurately is it there he he was
through that he saw a pitcher Polaroid
picture of me on ER and in the
production office in Manhattan where
they were they were housing the movie
Bullitt almost it was I believe it
it's a deranged read now it's on the
corner right over there arm by Lasky
know like Lafayette and like spring over
there in that area um and uh yeah he uh
he claims he saw my picture and he said
in his words you know I had already been
cut in my face so he told the director
Julianne temple I believe it was on that
go find me because he said I looked up
that enough to play the role of his
little brother no kidding did you ever
meet with him yeah yeah he was intense
he was really intense um you know what
you didn't say much around park you just
you know you kind of just did this kind
of thing just you just let him rip and
we just listened to him and um but I did
learn a lot from him I learned how to uh
I don't have to stand up for myself a
little bit on set when I when I my
opinion matter mm um he taught me that
he also taught me um to not come to set
and then get ready you come to set ready
leave their dressing room in character
when you come to set you're in character
you don't talk to that Park taught me
that and he taught me that by me
watching him it wasn't nothing he had to
tell me I would just you know be a fly
on the wall when he came in the room and
just observe him oh you know who he
learned that from at all you ever know
sir
with afraid he cussed me out next one
you met Felicia Pierson in a club
introduced the creators of the wire to
Felicia and they wrote the character and
Casarez snoop true story that is correct
no kidding yes sir it was like took
there was like 140 uh-huh and I was in
the VIP section
and friggin bartender Matt I was losing
faith that she was gonna make it back
before last call
you know the actual last call so I
decided to chip to the bar to get that
last call uh-huh and there she was and I
just she stopped me dead in my tracks I
couldn't stop staring at her I was like
this is either a very beautiful young
woman or a very pretty boy either way I
want to get to know her and she walked
over and she's he and her she actually
introduced herself to me and um we uh
we've been friends in it but we've been
family ever since it's awesome Omar
little was the only another on the only
major character on the wire to not use
profanity and you had complete control
to remove any curse words from your
script is that true that is true
laughter I'm a well first of all David
and and and they wrote him as a man that
did not use profanity but you know as TV
shows move on you know they hire
different writers David was in the
writing room you know and things were
moving and um you know certain writers
would come in and they were certain
certain times and certain scripts with
certain curse words slipped through the
filter and I remember it's like you know
I said I called us a day no no no we got
this thing where Omar don't you know he
was like nah from now on you see in
doubt that was a typo you see any more
profanity and you're in your dialogue
you you had the right he told me that
yeah but I had to get he gave me the
right to do it
where did it all mark come and come from
did you make that up with Omar coming no
sir that was all that was all in the
script okay what about honey nut
cheerios all in the script did you ever
ask what why honey nut cheerios it was
something that you had to eat I was so
grateful it wasn't oh we with the we
shredded wheat my mother said you do not
look the gift horse in the mouth
Cheerios and honey no I know I died and
gone to heaven honey that's great
every summer I did I think of you and we
are my wife and I we have matching Omar
coming to say word we do that's a fact
no I know I appreciate it I don't know
if it's
me anymore but honestly but uh next time
we uh we have you on I would love to had
to come back sign that up so before I
let you go two things do you want to
give any thoughts on the passing of
Nipsey Hussle do you have any thoughts
on what happened that you'd like to have
the Florida you know um yes yes I would
uh i-i've been um um that hit me to my
core you know first of all I just met
him just a month ago and um in full
disclosure I had no idea of all the good
he was doing in the community until
after this incident happened so uh I'm
um I can't tell you what an idiot I feel
like it how much this is really killing
me um on the inside I recently started
I'm developing a project a non-scripted
project um around community pride and
the premise of this the show for me the
foundation was the question I asked
myself how come people from my community
when we find success we are taught and
conditioned to leave the very same
community that made us successful and it
was a it was a dog whistle to people
that from my community that have reached
a certain level of success whether it be
entertainment whether it be dr. Loy
whatever your field was it was a dog
whistle to them to let's find ways to to
really give back to our community and
not feel like everything we did had to
be for the sole reason of getting out
the other side of success is yeah if you
choose to get out that's part of it but
the other half should be able to come
back home because it is home for me and
so Nipsey Hussle was the poster child
for for that for me you know and so now
you know I aspire to be like that young
man to put my money where my mouth is to
really have an impact on the community
and to have that image to have that that
example so violently snuffed out um I'm
hurting on another level that I
never really felt before but um if it's
one thing I know that didn't if I didn't
know before it's all my community my
children my little brothers and sisters
they need me now more than ever this
can't be the only narrative that comes
out of my community and um I don't care
what Crenshaw is still a beautiful a
beautiful place with beautiful people
and I would still be blessed and be
honored to walk the streets of Crenshaw
and meet the people and and I refuse to
let a situation like this make me afraid
to go home and I coach anybody else to
do the same well making kids wyndcomm
what's that website in that organization
about Michael making kids witness my my
um my way of just uh you know ensuring
that there are no more situations like
this no more Central Park fires I did I
just want to be accountable and do my
part as a man from my community so
making kids win is a foundation where
you know we're going to partner with
other um grassroots community that are
already boots on ground doing the work
like my friend and sister Dana ratchet
from your home town Staten Island who
has a NYC together that org we just want
to put things in the community and you
know I hate using the word programming
because it's basically just it's normal
things that should be in the community
already but because it's not there we
have to make like we're doing something
you know spectacular by putting
programming and back in the communities
so that's what we're doing in ways and
things like you know arm trauma
counseling through the Arts which is
something that's really huge for me um
they helped me a lot as a young man
coming up urban agriculture but not just
so um planning and our fruits and
vegetables and selling it to the farmers
market we're gonna teach them how to do
microgreens we can do that in your
apartment and how to cope press you can
make something you can actually sell and
put back into the community something
healthy education meeting them on any
level that there are to get into another
level whatever that may be and lastly to
arm-to-arm create a certified
classification called um
officers we can hire formerly
incarcerated men and women men and women
and use their education to help us steer
the youth in making more healthier
choices so um you know when I'm I'm not
uh working on you know Michael the actor
this is pieces will you'll find me
making kids wyndcomm and again you
mentioned Central Park five that's what
the Netflix series when they see us is
exactly about four part series that
you're part of on Netflix that that
begins to start streaming on the last
day of May May 31st obviously I will see
anything that you were in I'm not saying
that cuz you come down here when when I
heard you were booked on this show I've
got extremely excited called my wife
we'd been big fans of yours for for a
long time yours I tell you well the
actors next time I come to yes you've
got to bring you all Morticia by my side
absolutely fantastic I'd love it any
time at BK BMG both on Instagram and
Twitter for a Michael K Williams check
out the public in theaters today right
now good to see you sir the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience